double shift remember so I won't see you
tomorrow you gonna be okay oh yeah I got
dinner oh god honey can you just clean
up a little bit I'll try don't expect
much okay oh when I get home you will
yes Anne is amazing she takes care of me
she takes care of sick people sick
babies she is an angel and I seriously
love her hard she's going to be gone for
the next 24 hours so I made this list
and basically this place is gonna be
like a sparkling palace when she returns
I took a bunch of painkillers they're
about to kick in so I'm ready to go I
wish I could say some of this mess was
Anne's but it's all mine I'm kind of a
nester not bad for a guy with two broken
legs
there's only one more thing I need to
clean me I can't really get into a
shower so I got this idea for my parents
this is how they clean their dog like
that huh
I wrote that for Ann it's gonna be
playing when she walks through the door
today and check this out
washed my shorts any like that okay turn
that down no I wrote that song
I don't care turn it down what are you
doing in my yard Lawrence get out of
here
okay you know what I'm taking put that
my boombox it's my boombox now I asked
you nicely do not ask me nicely put that
down
I just put 12 new batteries that die
Oh ports come on give it this back
inside Hank
you